So here we have tin, but this is a different
sample of tin from
what people might be used to because most
people see tin in
foil, or they think it is tin foil that they
use to wrap up the
chicken, mostly that is aluminium foil.
Tin has the symbol Sn because it comes from
the Latin word
stannum which means tin and in fact if you
go to Devon in
the southwest of England you will find that
some of the
towns there are called stannary towns because
that’s where
they used to mine and trade in tin. Tin has
a very old role in
trade and in technology. Bronze which people
used in the old
days was an alloy of tin and copper which
gave better swords
than copper, so if you were fighting with
somebody who had
a copper sword and you had a bronze one, you
won, at least
if you were quick.
Here we see a beautiful sample of tin metal
and you can see it
is a really beautiful rod and it is packaged
in glass to stop
oxidation, but you can see a beautiful silvery
shiny metal.
Tin has also been used very widely for coating
the insides of
iron and steel containers for food, that’s
why they are called
tin even though they were made from iron but
they had a
thin coating of tin on the surface, and tin
is also used very
widely for solder, for putting together metal
components or
electronic components.
Lovely sample of tin, so we will pop that
back in and back
into the drawer.